E.J.'S NEAT-O STAT THE NIGHT.
>> SPONSORED BY?
NO ONE!
I'M GOING TO SHOW MY AGE A
LITTLE BIT HERE.
I WONDER IF YOU GUYS ARE ALSO
POSSIBLY FAMILIAR WITH THE BAND
YES?
>> UH-HUH.
>> YES FROM THE '70s AND '80s
AND STILL PLAYING.
SO THEY HAVE ONE NUMBER ONE
SONG.
GUESS THAT.
"OWNER OF A LONELY HEART."
♪ OWNER OF A LONELY HEART ♪
>> SOUNDS A LITTLE BIT LIKE THAT
BUT HERE IS A CLIP.
>> THIS IS MY BAND IN HIGH
SCHOOL.
♪♪
>> WERE IN A BEDROOM MAKING THAT
VIDEO?
>> THAT BEAT IS CRAZY.
>> A GREAT BEAT BUT MADE A VIDEO
IN THEIR BEDROOM.
>> THE GUY PLAYING LEAD GUITAR
THERE TREVOR RAYBURN IS HIS
NAME, OKAY?
YOU KNOW WHAT ELSE TREVOR
RAYBURN IS FAMOUS FOR?
>> WHAT IS THAT?
>> THIS SONG.
>> HE MADE THAT?
>> YES, WAY BACK AROUND IN 2002,
2003, HE CAME UP WITH THE THEME
SONG AND TREVOR JOINS US FROM
LOS ANGELES!
>> HEY THERE, TREVOR!
>> HI.
>> HOW ARE YOU?
>> I'M GOOD.
HOW ARE YOU DOING?
>> NUMBER ONE, WE THANK SO MUCH
FOR YOUR WORK ON COMPOSING THAT
THEME MUSIC BECAUSE, MAN, IT HAS
STAYING POWER AND IT IS JUST
IMMEDIATELY RECOGNIZABLE TO SAY,
THE NBA ON TNT IS ON.
HOW DID YOU COME UP WITH THE
IDEA?
WHAT DROVE YOU TO THAT?
>> AS FAR AS IT GOES, I REMEMBER
WHEN KEVIN McHALE WAS CLOTHES
LINED.
THE BEGINNING OF IT WAS KIND OF
THE AGGRESSION THAT HOPEFULLY
THAT BROUGHT.
BUT I REALLY JUST WANTED TO
WRITE A THEME THAT WOULD BE
MEMORABLE AND BROKE SOME BARE
BARRIERS THERE FOR SPORTS THEME
AND BROUGHT SOME ROCK 'N' ROLL
IN AND USED THE ORCHESTRA AS
WELL, OBVIOUSLY.
>> WAS IT SPECIFICALLY MADE FOR
US?
OR YOU HAD IT WORKING ON ANOTHER
SONG?
>> NO.
IT WAS SPECIFICALLY DONE FOR THE
SHOW.
AND IT WAS GREAT.
I HAD SUCH FUN DOING IT.
IT'S FUNNY, BECAUSE I DO PHONE
SCORES AND ONE WAS A PHONE
"REMEMBER THE TITANS" FOR DENZEL
WASHINGTON AND THEY ASKED ME TO
DO IT AND I JUMPED AT IT BECAUSE
I LOVE BASKETBALL.
>> HOW MANY TIMES HAVE YOU
PERFORMED AND PLAYED "OWNER OF A
LONELY HEART"?
I THINK UREACHED A MILLION TIMES
YET?
>> I THINK 500 TIMES WHEN I WAS
WRITING IT.
SINCE THEN, THOUSANDS OF TIMES
ON THE ROAD.
YEAH.
IN FACT, I REMEMBER ONE CONCERT
I DID, WE WERE PLAYING THE
SUMMIT.
THE NIGHT BEFORE WE WERE AT THE
HOTEL, I SAW CHARLES WALKING
THROUGH.
I GUESS YOU WERE PLAYING -- YOU
WERE PLAYING IN HOUSTON AND WE
PLAYED THE NEXT NIGHT.
YOU WON.
>> MY QUESTION AS A GREAT SONG
WRITER, COMPOSER, WOULD THERE BE
A MELODY TO THAT TNT SONG?
AND IF IT HAD A HOOK, WHAT WOULD
IT BE?
>> OH, BOY, THAT'S A GOOD
QUESTION.
I'D HAVE TO THINK ABOUT THAT.
BASICALLY, I WOULD JUST WRITE
LYRICS OVER THE THEME THAT IT IS
AND MAYBE I CAN USE SOME
CROATIAN -- NO.
>> TREVOR, I GOT A QUESTION FOR
YOU.
WHAT IS BETTER?
WRITING A GREAT SONG OR SINGING
A GREAT SONG?
>> I THINK THE WRITING IS THE
MOST SATISFYING THING, BUT, YOU
KNOW, BEING ON THE ROAD IS
SOMETHING, WHICH HAS ALWAYS BEEN
SO GREAT, SUCH A THRILL.
>> WE APPRECIATE IT AND WE
ENCOURAGE FOLKS TO CHECK OUT
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" ARTICLE
THAT PROFILED YOU THE OTHER DAY
AND TALKED ABOUT THE HISTORY OF
THE THEME SONG AND IT'S GREAT TO
PUT A FACE WITH THE MUSIC,
TREVOR.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR GREAT
WORK AND YOU'VE KIND OF GIVEN US
THE SIGNATURE MUSIC FOR OUR SHOW
FOR AS LONG AS A LOT OF US HAVE
BEEN HERE.
WE APPRECIATE THAT.
>> THANK YOU!
>> THANK YOU SO MUCH.
IT WAS GREAT FUN.
>> TREVOR RABIN, THE MAN WHO
COMPOSED THE THEME SONG.
>> YOU NEVER WHAT ABOUT
MUSICIANS?
EVERY BASKETBALL PLAYER WANTED
TO BE A MUSICIAN.
>> DID YOU WANT TO B